[ __ ] Patel Patriot I don't know this guy
and it's also because we have a guest
and last week we played the video and
and we were we were like we need we need
to talk to this woman what she did she
stood up for so many for so many of the
of the little guys and um bare knuckle
brawling champion of Waffle House that's
right uh the the last chairbender
goes by Waffle House Wendy
hi Haley would you prefer is that is
that the best Haley should we just call
you that is that right y'all can call me
Haley if you want okay good good I just
wanted to make sure that we weren't you
know let me turn the chroma key I don't
have that on there you go so what's it
like being in a viral video fighting in
a waffle house but for it to be somehow
still an extraordinary video because I
mean let's be honest Waffle House brawl
videos they're a dime a dozen but uh
this one's sort of this one's sort of
it's got people going yeah and I don't
know if you know this and I know you
told me that that you're taken but you
have a lot of simps out there now too
you have a lot of people making marriage
proposals as we speak in the chat marry
me Haley yeah so I mean now walk us back
now remember correctly this video
actually happened last year in September
correct
yeah all right so so we we've all seen
the video what what happened here
besides it being a Waffle House what
happened here
well I was the only cook that night I
had already cooked you know a bunch of
food by myself at that point and I still
had 30 40 people in line these ladies
had came in and they were being Rowdy
already and they sat in a closed-off
section of the store we had closed it
off
bro yeah go ahead try that's right and
um so I had seen him nobody else had saw
him so I had seen them and said hey
ladies I see y'all you know I've got a
bunch of people on Huddy y'all if y'all
need anything to drink let us know you
know if you need anything but it's going
to take a minute you know
um they come up they start you know uh
oh girl in the leopard print pants she
came up let me get some water let us get
some teas okay you're drunk cool
and um yeah
khaki pants my volume yeah yeah
and um
so they get us somewhat we get her some
water we get them all some drinks and
stuff well a couple minutes later they
started asking for food hey let me get
some hash browns let me get you know
cheese steak
I said hey y'all you know I still got 20
tickets ahead of y'all
um
I'll
be with you as soon as I can you know I
appreciate your patience I know it's
slow but I'm working as fast as I can I
can't cook food any faster than the food
Cooks
and um
they start you know oh well I'ma make
that girl cook my food I'm gonna make
that white girl cook my food but using
much more colorful language and um
they start getting belligerent and kind
of making threats so I said if y'all
keep acting rude I'm just not going to
cook you food I'm the only cook that
night if I don't cook it you're not
gonna it's not gonna get cooked
well
that's when the video picks up because
my manager they start getting loud my
manager starts walking over
to talk to them
and they start getting you know Rowdy
and rowdy
the girl who fell off the counter with
the thick braids she it actually already
crossed into the employee side tossing
silver there she is there she is this
one right yeah okay
yeah that woman calling was one of the
funniest things ever and by the way I'm
thank you for also you posted two
different angles of it on your Twitter
which which is [ __ ] amazing to see
her fall from the other side because you
guys you see her go ahead first down it
was so funny so anyway sorry your head
actually landed on my manager's shoe
holy [ __ ] that's amazing so okay so she
stands up there I see that she gets off
uh obviously they're every it's kind of
understand what people are saying
specifically because the guy that's
filming it won't shut the [ __ ] up
um so I see that what's thrown at her at
this point I thought um I actually I
picked up the coffee pot and I realize
it's not heavy and
heavy and it down and I
and I'm sitting on the high bar right in
front of it and I throw it at the chair
in front of her I was wondering what
that was I thought it was a plate but I
was like it looked like it shattered
into like sand I'm like what is it that
makes sense it was the [ __ ] sugar
that was let me tell you what let me
just tell you why I love you Haley
because everyone glossed over it but she
said I picked up the coffee pot but it
wasn't heavy enough
that's something heavier that's [ __ ]
awesome okay so what you threw was the
the sugar container right for the coffee
yeah yeah you could would you put in
your coffee yeah so there you go here
have some sugar sugar that should have
said that okay next time let me know I
have catchphrases
right so you throw the sugar now this is
probably well there's two favorites I
like I like my man in the back here just
being like man my man in the back has
that posture as somebody that got called
in and it wasn't even his day to work
and he's just like man like why am I in
here doing this [ __ ] this this was um
this was this was so so you you throw uh
you throw the um you you throw the sugar
uh then she this this one gets on uh
this one gets on the on the table here
and then she
slips and okay now was that your manager
that was trying to catch her
yeah yeah that he tried to catch her and
if you actually slow it down enough I
actually went to pick her up to help her
up because she fell I thought that was
going to be enough embarrassment you
just fell off the counter yeah so did we
um and she made eye contact with me I
see that with me again
I that's
so so right here I see that I slowed it
down like you said so she looks like she
slips she falls and the manager tries to
catch the catch her and then I see that
yeah you walk up like you're gonna help
her up like that you put your hand down
to help her up and then
boom okay so why why do you okay now the
uppercuts by the way great uppercuts
people have been asking me do you have
any professional like fights yeah
where'd you learn to scrap
I so my stepdad taught me how to
actually throw a punch okay
but I have no real training I've been in
a lot of unsavory situations with
ex-boyfriends ex-girlfriends and I had
to learn or have you ever been to jail
you don't all right you don't have to
talk we're not we're not judging I'm not
judging we're not sure I'm just saying
like that that was some jail punches man
yeah that was something like that was
younger
thing hey we look I've been to jail too
yeah so so don't worry about judging
we're not we're not good boys we're not
just curious yeah I'm not a model
citizen we have we have a commercial
about getting retards guns it's not like
we're like the best example yeah I only
met because when I first watched that
video I think I said that on the show
I'm like that that's that girl fights
like somebody who's been to jail yeah I
mean or at least juvie yeah
those uppercuts were [ __ ] a thing of
beauty by the way because you know a few
a few of our fans were saying stuff like
you know everyone everyone's focusing on
on uh on the chair thing which we're
about to get to but like your uppercuts
are pretty good you hit it with a couple
here but and by the way I'm a big
believer once you cross over to the once
you cross over the any counter you're
fair game now like that's oh yeah I've
always believed that that's like jumping
in a wrestling ring or jumping over a
bar you're getting stomped yeah that's
it Waffle House actually has wool and
they tell you in orientation
if you look back behind the counter
where the opening is it changes from
that white and black tile to this bumpy
stuff right right once you if a customer
crosses over to that bumpy self Waffle
House employees can take any means
necessary to ensure their safety right
no of course so the moment she came over
and by um you give her these couple of
uppercuts well she said was she saying
something at that point there's good
uppercuts yeah by the way holding her
hair [ __ ] pro move pro move with a
hold of the hair some hockey fights I
didn't want to catch her in the nose so
I had to pick her head up to get a
better ankle on her chin this was well
thought out Jesus wow man holy [ __ ] I
was trying to get the proper angle and
you did by the way I didn't want to I
didn't want to actually hurt her yeah
right I didn't want to break anything it
was about sending a message which you
did send a message
um so right here you know you come in
and I'm you you give her you give her a
couple shots out now is who who's
pulling you off of her those look like
other customers correct
um those were her friends actually they
those so though it was those two on
front of the counter and then there was
three more still sitting over at the
table and that's a straight shot too so
as soon as they saw me
um like start swinging on her they ran
into and they all had all five of them
they grabbed me by my ponytail
so okay I was sitting there trying to
pull us apart so they're swarming you
like zombies yeah I did see that part
where they started they started wailing
on her and she's right right she
actually stood tall I was like damn yeah
they they did they get any good shots in
on you
I mean with everybody in the way there
was like one that caught me on the side
of my head right before I started to
block but it wasn't that good it wasn't
like a hard hit
right so yeah right here boom yeah
that's the one that I I saw
um so now you got a couple of them
hitting you there at the same mind you
keep in mind
any this video there's no way to look at
this video other than they went in like
merch said you went into a boxing ring
you went into a wrestling ring you went
on a field you're not that's the area
you're not supposed to be at so honestly
whatever happens at that point is on you
and also yeah especially if you I mean
look everybody listen this is we've
talked about this before but I've always
believed that there's something that we
like to call here The Waffle House
treaty right where it's like look
everyone at 4am at the waffles probably
drunk drove there they're on drugs
they're doing something or they're cops
eating I've never been in a Waffle House
sober no that's very good point in my
life I don't think anybody's been in a
waffle house over besides children right
and even and even still they're buzzed
so they're buzzed a little no but but my
point is like I've been in a waffle
house where I've seen a definitely a
meth dealer sitting next to two cops
taking their [ __ ] their their their
lunch break at like four in the morning
because they're all working overnight
and everyone leaves each other alone as
long as you're not being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] people will leave you alone but
the moment you start acting routing yeah
you walk into a waffle house it's like
you're walking into a house where
everybody respects each other right
and it once you come in and start
disrespecting people that are just
trying to do their job yeah like all all
I was trying to do was feed 30 to 40
people at one time
you know it's not gonna happen instant
like you instant like you're at a
McDonald's or a Chick-fil-A or or
Wendy's or whatever try the actual
sit-down restaurant I have to pull the
raw food out and cook it in front of you
no so you you have you worked like in
the service industry for a couple years
like as far as like this I've actually
only been in the food service industry
since I was 16 years old but long enough
to because I wanted to add like have you
noticed like I don't know like has it
gotten worse like as far as like patrons
and customers just like just acting at
just wilding out like they get crazy I
believe it's acting the fool yeah there
you go yeah people people look at Food
Service workers and and customer service
workers like they're nothing but the the
quote-unquote better term to say but the
help right of course so they look down
on you but what people got to remember
is what 20 20 when the world's shut down
essential workers were First Responders
Hospital workers and Food Service
workers
um
because
because if if if you these people aren't
working if these people aren't making
your food you have to go home and make
your chicken sandwich your chicken
nuggets your right you know whatever you
have to learn how to cook it right and
Waffle Houses Waffle House in any place
that opened 24 hours are the places that
allow you to get drunk and then still
eat so you have to cook when you get
home so I never understood that but then
again you are dealing with a bunch of
[ __ ] drunk people which I'm sure
doesn't help
um shout out yeah shut up you get
impatient shout out to those
[ __ ] too for being the only
place open in like North Carolina on
Christmas yeah that sure was still over
everything was closed and I was like man
every time I passed the Waffle House I
was like yo those people in there we
have this thing in the South where
depending on how bad the hurricane is
depending on whether or not the waffle
house is open oh yeah that's I mean
we're from Florida we know I mean we
we're in Florida we know all about it
the Waffle House we use the Waffle House
rating system so you got like you got
[ __ ] over for this though right like
you got fired or something actually I
did not get fired for this fight the
only thing that I got from this fight
was I gotta ride up for breaking the
sugar shaker
that's that is amazing that's hilarious
I heard you got like that I heard you
got Blacklist or something I did get
black there it is but I moved two months
later my relationship with my boyfriend
was getting serious and we moved I had
to move cities
and they did the the old-fashioned if I
can't have you nobody can
and they had said Haley you're always
welcome back at this store you know
whatever if you ever need a job we're
here
and I had went to visit a friend in
North Carolina for like six months and
tried to work at a Waffle House there
because I needed some money and I know
it's good money and you know easy work
and they had told me that I was
blacklisted so
so yeah so they wouldn't even let you
work it out that seems ridiculous yeah
it's kind of shitty and why would that
make me ever want to go back to work for
you then yeah you know what I mean like
if you're gonna go out and have me
blacklisted for [ __ ] I still eat there
it's still good food that's so good yeah
look listen Haley we all get drunk at
four in the morning we all go to Waffle
House trust me trust me I'm not gonna
boycott them or anything I can't it's
physically it's possible you're drunk at
3 30 in the morning that's sweet what am
I gonna do cook eggs I'm not [ __ ]
crazy exactly and
um so just to continue here with a
little bit more of the video uh so I
think at this point she's she's yelling
something she's making a scene after by
the way being [ __ ] embarrassed
um and one of the other angles
um one of my co-workers Alexis she had
taken a coffee pot full of hot water out
of a coffee pot and actually splashed
some of the girls with it oh here's
another ring okay so she was yeah she
was yelling y'all wanna you wanna Splash
me with a hot water
okay so here okay so is this here I got
another angle tummy is
hold on is this is this is this the
angle
that's that's the angle but that's
actually a nine second video there's
like a two or three yeah yeah that you
post that you posted later here tell you
what let me just go through your Twitter
uh was
it this one it should be yeah I found
another angle y'all okay this one got it
okay
um
yeah yeah the one that's filming yeah so
he walks in
so I'm assuming nobody paid
well of course they're not gonna pay
come on and and the and the thing is
even after
after a chair at me I saw
I saw top on top of the counter and I
was like real talk the fight's over is
this your wallet and you could actually
hear me ask her is this your wallet and
she shook her head no one tosses another
plate of Buddha
so it you know it it so at this see this
is uh okay there it is okay through the
hot water at her okay got it
and then she goes back and she throws
that and there okay look this is the
thing that I the other actually for this
food I think the other angle is a little
bit better multiple chair Dodges yeah
okay so so now let's let's get into my
favorite part of this video one of my
favorite there's two favorite well three
now but actually now that you've
mentioned the sugar thing now that's
another favorite part of the video so
um this this part comes here we got the
punches this guy walks back in
and then
um so he walks back in let me move it
out of slow motion here uh let's go to
normal speed
um
she picked something else up it falls
out of her hands
uh
uh let's see this it's right around here
when the guy walks back in
okay here we go here we go um what a
vibrant culture she threw okay so the
first thing that she throws is a booster
chair right like a little like a high a
a high chair for a kid is that what that
is yeah okay and then she throws a chair
and and okay
I gotta ask look how did you pull this
move off
like was it was pick up my hands to stop
it from hitting me in the face I I mean
I get it but it's one of those things
where you might have done it by mistake
but that looked like so that you
couldn't feel you could film that a
hundred times and not pull that off
again right you know what I mean
probably not she throws it and then you
went
and then
put the the defiant stance the defiant
stance is what cuts me I know it's like
[ __ ] you that was when the whole
internet fell in love with her right I
was like okay there it is
because my whole thing was you're really
gonna get mad and gang up on somebody
and throw a chair later yeah so so
here's the thing and then after they
missed this part here well some folks
have no agency yeah that's a good point
and they're also drunk I mean keep in
mind all these people are [ __ ]
hammers they're intoxicated during all
of this well you're intoxicated your
your ration goes like down the drain I
mean I don't know I mean I've been
hammered and I've been a little
impatient about some of this before but
I've never flung a chair over it you
know it's like okay is it gonna take a
while what are we doing I think at this
point is that everyone was so [ __ ]
embarrassed because of the falling down
and looking at idiots it's like you just
triple down it's understandable so
right here
um she has another chair and this is the
part this is what I said forget the
chair thing forget the uppercuts forget
all that oh yeah it's the greatest part
here when you were like give little
Dwayne The Rock when you when you were
like Bring It On
yeah I was I was sitting there telling
her throw it I'll catch it like the last
one
that's [ __ ] amazing
um and by the way somebody's saying out
of 10 they're saying you're a 17 out of
10 because you're compassionate to your
attackers is what a king of all pixels
just said there you go yeah it's like
one thing to fight you fight me in the
battlefield but I still have honor is
this your wallet is this your wallet
he's like that's still her property like
you could you could go home and be like
oh [ __ ] I left my I lost my wallet and I
I you could be embarrassed and not want
to go back right but but it's so it's
like you know and then all you wanted to
run in again too so uh so they then of
course the whole like throw another one
I [ __ ] dare you come on bring it and
by the way I love the fact that you stay
you stay in your in your designated area
which you're playing by all the rules
and still winning and somebody's calling
you a shield Maiden
um I don't know if I want to marry this
chick or meet her in the Octagon hobo
chili recipe said so that's it you
swatted another one
I think she's just what ip2 needs yeah I
like that I think Trenton Wade would
agree with me so you you were I mean so
then the next thing this video is a year
old for some reason I don't remember
exactly who posted it again but it kind
of blew up again uh it came up it was
the original it was the guy who took the
video who took this video he posted it
again right the the first two video the
other two videos that I posted on my
Twitter those were actually posted like
the day after right the fight that was
on Facebook and I think one of them was
on Tick Tock and it didn't I guess
nobody had caught that perfect angle so
it just it went unseen yeah and you know
what happens or just sometimes depending
on what the algorithm pushes
um yeah and sometimes somebody just
picks something up and it's the right
person to retweet it or something and
you're like okay and whoever and whoever
took this video thank you because like
this this is some good yeah well I mean
look for you it's amazing like when when
our producer when our producer found
your Twitter you only had like 700
people and now you're like 16 000 people
following you know it blows my mind and
all this art and the memes that are
coming out like it's I feel honored oh
yeah they are people to like turn me
into art so what's your what's your
plans now what are you gonna do yeah
I actually am working with an artist in
a company
um I'm gonna go up to Tulsa and have
some shirts made and just hand sign them
do a little meet and greet for people
um the money that people are donating
um I'm putting into like paying for the
labor and I'm also donating some to uh a
couple of things for domestic violence
that's pretty that's pretty cool
yeah I mean that's a noble cause I know
that's that's awesome and you know it's
it's nice to see it's nice to see people
standing up for themselves because we
play on this show a lot of videos where
people just like you know just breaking
in the Walgreens and stealing [ __ ] and
everyone let them do whatever they want
I mean and by the way I will say this
this meme is a joke but like stand alone
if you must but you must stand you you
stood you stood by yourself and that's
not an easy situation I mean you were
surrounded you're getting popped I was
terrified the whole time where me and
her were sitting there going and they
were starting to gang up on me there's
big knives over there I have oh yeah and
I'm trying that I'm you know I'm trying
to get back and all kinds of stuff
because issues and whatnot and you know
all I'm doing is trying to get my son
back and you know have my family back
together and if I if one of those ladies
had grabbed that knife and just wanted
to cut me or if somebody had a gun that
night it would just as well be an
obituary instead of a meme oh yeah I
mean absolutely but I mean so so that I
mean no use in getting killed over some
eggs yeah exactly
people it's waffles it's breakfast food
I mean yeah it's good but is it really
worth going to jail or losing your life
or whatever about I don't know the viral
videos tell me yes I mean every day I
just see people like punching [ __ ]
flight attendants and getting federal
charges and you're like bro it's a
two-hour flight chill just [ __ ] chill
man we all want to get off the plane we
all want a cigarette right now or a
drink or a [ __ ] slice of pizza but
you just have to sit still for two and a
half hours all right stop hitting people
I mean you know it it really it really
is it really is uh kind of cool that you
stood up and you know I'm always very
happy when people actually get
recognized for like [ __ ] standing up
for themselves and doing the right thing
well more people did it then less people
would be [ __ ] trying everybody all
the time and especially because you did
it was it wasn't a situation where you
even knew you were being filmed it was a
situation like [ __ ] you and you know it
was one of those 401 this crack of [ __ ]
ain't gonna [ __ ] do nothing to me and
then it was like oh boy you see this is
why you don't pick random people because
five five I'm five five a buck 80. I
don't look threatening
no I yeah well I mean now you do or you
[ __ ] off now you do I I think I would
get the point though with the first
chair block yeah you know what I mean
look all right you did that I'd be like
she's some sort of waffle wizard so I'm
gonna leave her alone I'm not messing
with this [ __ ] sorry I apologize I left
a tip on the table Yeah Yeah and yes
that is my wallet thank you
you can keep my wallet I'm out of here
so you run away you run away like that
fat guy and Breaking Bad and [ __ ]
Mike it's the guy in the throat and he's
like he just turns he kind of runs away
I don't understand it's like the first
time one bullet bounces off Superman why
keep shooting the moment when once you
you throw one chair why throw another
one I don't know I mean if I'm shooting
at Superman and one bullet bounces off I
mean I still have 12 more the chair in
her hand that's a good she already had
her hair she wanted to look stupid she
don't want to look stupid it was already
in her hand but you know the the fact
that you did the [ __ ] bring it was
one of my favorite Parts
um and and by the way waffle waffle
wizard is another nickname you could
have I saw the screenshot of her doing
that [ __ ] that bringing [ __ ] all over
oh I know dude just with a million simp
comments just a million super comments
like this girl marry me please let's
talk about The Simpsons you are getting
inundated with Sims huh you got right
yeah you got you got you got people that
are in love with you now which is funny
and um oh my God I had not seen this one
and I just saw you posted it did you did
you see the did you see the the did you
see Marsh this one with the John Cena
yeah
fluid it looks real okay so check this
out so here I'll say Marsha I didn't see
anything like this here you go
[Applause]
that's very funny bro these deep fakes
are hilarious holy [ __ ] that's so that
was so well done
um
yeah I mean you know honestly it really
it really is amazing here's what I'm
thinking how old are you now
25 look you're young enough Dana White's
always looking for people in the UFC I'm
just saying man you start training you
get in there he might hit you he does
that sometimes but that's Dana yeah he
gets a little hitty but yeah but that's
he gets angry unless you're his wife and
you slap him you're probably fine but
it's it it really it really is it really
is cool that I mean you know in honestly
enjoy the fame and I'll tell you
something spin it off into something do
something do it sounds like she's got
something going now she's a good [ __ ]
you know she's gonna be raising money
for domestic violence get some T-shirts
out they could be an influencer
try working into something helping at
least Food Service workers or customer
service workers getting some help at
least on late night shifts yeah I want
to get on ip2 I want to send her out I
want to get her kicking the [ __ ] out of
like Alicia Jordana and [ __ ] Gucci's
and just I want it just terrorizing the
ip2 streamers and beating the [ __ ] out
of them and don't like just violence I
mean oh no
[Music]
no you do it I don't see a point in it
yeah well and I love the UFC I love
mixed martial arts and all that other
stuff and I would love to actually get
really trained because I know I can
learn so much more than what I actually
know he wrote they made her an anime I
was actually showing them some of the
art some of the art that's come out has
been really amazing the anime stuff is
[ __ ] fantastic I mean that that
really is the heart that I've seen is
absolutely amazing and it and it blows
me out of the water it's unbelievable
you're 25 and you're just straight up
murdering [ __ ] out there and that's
and that's a comp no it is unarms
unarmed murdering [ __ ] out there look
and I know you're being humble I know
you don't have done violence but here's
the thing they didn't draw you didn't
draw first blood they did so at that
point you're well within your rights to
throw those [ __ ] uppercuts I mean um
listen hear me out Waffle House Wendy
podcast on Rumble I do it what's the you
already have a built-in fan base do that
and what you do is you go around town to
town all right and you sanction fights
at different Waffle Houses for Rowdy
customers so like Street beefs but it
only takes place so Waffle House when he
shows up right and she's like and she
shows up and she goes who's the worst
customer and she goes let's [ __ ] take
care of it and it just starts knocking
and we'll have like Street beefs where
they're not even dressed for fighting
they're out there fighting in jeans
exactly yeah they're just shirtless and
jeans all she does is she shows up she
shows up she just she cleans her hands
and she puts on her apron she goes who's
up I like this let's go that way you're
not fighting you're just the ref right
and then afterwards what she does like
Dog The Bounty here she smokes a
cigarette with him and eats breakfast
with them too he'll praise and praise
yeah it's dude I'm telling you we we
could help listen with the championship
belt exactly dude I'm telling you get a
[ __ ] the spinning belt like seeing a
spinning belt okay well Waffle House
Wendy's two W's already anyway you get
the Waffle House Wendy spinning belt
just make sure you don't store your belt
anywhere you got to hold on to it
yourself yeah carry it every little bit
of damage
yeah I hear people's belts get damaged
when I put them in storage there you go
if you don't want to get hit wrestling
going to wrestling dude
yeah
let's do it
why not Waffle House Wendy versus dick
Masterson let's go then he can break
another he'll be he'll be done he'll
break another name yeah he'll break a
knee on the flight there
glass Joe over here
um look I I'm I'm saying I you you have
you've been wonderful to talk to you
were even more pleasant than we expected
I mean yeah you're a lot of fun ones
like for real I I I wish you nothing but
and it's nice to hear you throwing like
domestic violence and you got a good
[ __ ] you know you said that's
actually really cool because yeah no pun
intended because I know where it's on my
Waffle House what's that egg get it
what's don't do that what's the I hate
you I hate you you know sold my Good Egg
lines yes I did because it was
bad I enjoyed it she enjoyed it because
okay you know what listen
chair I'm gonna throw something at Mercy
see if he's good as you are
uh what's what's that GoFundMe uh what's
it I know you have somebody made a
GoFundMe for her yeah it's like a
streamer what's the guy's name Mr brick
or brick something one of my I guess
fans his name is Brick suit um okay put
up a Twitter uh or sorry not he put up
uh GoFundMe contact me set up a GoFundMe
for me
um I think it's somewhere on my channel
I'll get it for you I'll get it for I'll
grab it
um and I'll share with you yeah yeah
yeah I got it whatever you want just
don't hit me
um please just please don't hit me
please don't hit me I don't want to get
hit um I I will I will I will uh I'll
post a GoFundMe there and that you know
that's honestly I don't even know that
when I talked to you before that you're
giving uh some of the money to to
cherish your domestic violence that's
actually really [ __ ] cool and that
that does really add a couple extra
points
um at least in my book
uh as far as that goes I know a lot of
people give GoFundMe some crap so if
people want to do like more direct my
cash app is also in my Twitter bio yes
yes that that string and GoFundMe is
kind of gay sometimes but
I there I mean if you're a Canadian
truck you're not even allowed to have
one um so uh there it is there okay I
post I just posted the link to your
GoFundMe there
um again you know Haley thank you so
much for being on I mean this this was
really cool I really enjoyed breaking
down this video I don't know of course I
mean you know um I'm sure you're gonna
be in a bunch of other shows and you
deserve to be you know you know I I
really yeah people are saying great kid
happy for her uh there's pretty much
everybody in here seems to like you even
more and it's not just simps there's
also like a woman so there you go
there's you're the two females here and
you're one of them
um we we really we really do appreciate
anything else you want to plug before we
let you go I mean I mean I mean if
anybody wants to know what my actual
Twitter handle is yes it's which Dragon
five which Dragon five I've been posting
it in the chat yes uh throughout the
show so yeah every once you're at 16.4
now
uh you know I'm sure they're gonna have
some net now because this is what
happens well I gotta fight people in a
waffle house is that how I get famous no
no you have to you have to win a fight
or the Waffle House oh so I've been
doing it wrong
first first
you have to win the you can't get beat
up at a waffle house I've just been
filming myself getting my ass kicked in
Waffle Houses every weekend yeah all
right well and honestly the fact that
Waffle House didn't capitalize on this
is [ __ ] stupid in my opinion like I
you you should be their spokesperson
because while father's pretending to be
anything that it's not which is just you
know this is what it is
I don't know man seems kind of silly but
hear me out wait so you're in Texas so
what do you go work at the Huddle House
or or Bob Evans
I think the closest
waffle house would be Joe's waffles okay
we've been to Texas a couple times what
that is
I remember like 15 years ago when I was
doing comedy on the road yeah past this
place in like near Myrtle Beach and you
it was built like a waffle house looks
just like a Waffle House and the guy
called it Mr waffle because he built it
and then he saw what the franchise fees
were and he's like [ __ ] you I can get
trunks to show up and eat breakfast I
don't need the waffle house so he's like
[ __ ] you 30 grand a year I'm just
calling it Mr [ __ ] but you could see the
building was built to be a Waffle House
like it was the same shape and
everything and he's like I'm painting
over that yellow I'm not [ __ ] paying
you guys pretty brilliant yeah and uh
that's another thing uh king of Paul
pixel says can she be the fight
correspondent for all your show so see
that's great should just throw to her
every time there's a [ __ ] I really
don't and by the way and I mean to say
that you are welcome on our show
whenever you'd like just let us know
honestly uh for any other stuff you you
plan on doing you want to plug let us
know you were honestly
a way better guess than you could expect
from somebody who got into a fight at a
Waffle House yeah and I mean honestly
you'll hire a security if we ever have
to get to an event yeah well I mean I
gotta treat people with respect like you
got you gotta everybody's got to be
treated like a basic human being
so you know if people people would do
that we'll be a better place so you know
I I come into a lot of things just basic
like that because we don't know each
other personally wait what what Alex
Stein okay Alex Stein texted me to read
this okay I gotta let me let me see her
before I let you go this is actually
might be related
this is no no this is a good thing this
isn't a bad thing no if it's Alex Stein
it's never a bad thing yeah give me give
me give me a second here I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'll tell them let them
know that we're on air
hold on I don't know I'm calling him
uh Alex good then he doesn't pick up
yeah nice what did he what's he saying
uh I'll show you I'll show you uh he
said hold on a second
awesome are they sending a car service
make
sure you are you doing some shows is
that is that what's going on because I'm
wondering if this is what this is about
hold on how many more shows actually
going on Fox News tonight
what show
um I'll be talking with Tuckers
that's what Alex Stein was calling me
about
that's what he was calling me about yeah
well we'll never be on that show ah you
[ __ ] us on top right Alex Alex Stein
beat us on Tucker and you beat us on
Tucker God damn it we're never gonna go
talk to Carlson
I'm going to [ __ ] somebody up in a
waffle house I might shoot somebody
tonight in a Waffle House hey Alex we're
live what we're on air what's up
the last chair Bender she's going on my
father's show tonight Tucker Carlson I
don't know if she revealed that
on too long I have to get her to that
studio so I don't know if you guys knew
that but I'm just finding this
information okay okay got it hey tell
you what we'll we'll let her go right
now that way she could get to the studio
how's that are you serious oh that's
what it was because you guys are so nice
I love you my dad would be so happy yeah
[Music]
tell him yeah just tell your dad to get
it tell him to thank us tell your dad to
get us on first yeah how about give us a
goddamn mention on that show okay I'm
gonna let I'm letting I'm letting I'm
letting her go right now okay just for
you buddy all right tell Dad we said hi
all right love you Buddy Bye all right
hey you know what all you had to say was
you were going on Tucker you don't have
to be nice to that nice to us it's a job
if you drop a revenge of the CIS
reference on Tucker that's a [ __ ]
scene anything if you just say one
revenge of the citizen Tucker will love
you forever we love you anyway we're
gonna let you go we have all your plugs
here go do what you got to do we'll have
you on some other time when you have a
little more time but take it easy so
much for coming on
take it easy
all right later
I'm gonna go shoot somebody in a Waffle
House
how does this work then
I'm scared and I don't know how any I
don't know any of this [ __ ] works I'm
[ __ ] scared all right I love that
this is Alex cause he goes she's got to
be on Tucker I'm like okay I'll let her
go
just want to get on Tucker I can't I
can't
that hurt yes it hurt that was [ __ ]
that was that was wild
that was wild what a wild day today has
been hey guys do you want to start the
new year off in a better way than that
because I don't think you can
better for all then I'm not going on
talker
so let me just thanks a lot Tucker let
me get this straight we were just big
timed
we were just big time by time because
his son called us Alex
somebody in a waffle house I'm not
shooting anybody in a waffle house then
I'll blow it up then what do you want me
to do what should I do